soon after the shooting at Paul's
nightclub in 2016 a lot of gay and
bisexual men realized something they
left him frustrated they were not
allowed to donate blood our coverage of
the deadly shooting in Orlando and the
outpouring of support from people
wanting to help the victims Southwest
Florida man overcome with emotion in the
wake of Orlando's deadly rampage he's
now trying to help the surviving victims
who are fighting for their lives there's
one problem he says he's been denied
from donating blood
more than once because he's gay based on
the current FDA restriction men who have
had sex with other men in the past 12
months are deferred from donating blood
but when was this put in place and why
initially this restriction was
introduced in 1983 and until recently it
was a lifetime ban for men who slept
with other men at this time the US was
in the midst of the AIDS crisis and
there was still a lot of ignorance about
HIV and it's transmission which shows
that the lifestyle of some male
homosexuals has triggered an epidemic of
a rare form of cancer researchers are
now studying blood and other samples
from the victims trying to learn what is
causing the disease so far they have had
no luck one of the things they knew was
that this was a blood-borne virus and
the virus was affecting mostly the gay
community at this time with their
limited research and knowledge it made
sense to have a temporary ban on blood
donations from gay men but what does
this ban mean now 35 years later the FDA
updated its ban in 2015 changing it to a
deferral for men who have had sex with
another man in the past 12 months so
essentially if you're gay and you want
to donate blood you just can't have sex
for a full year so like a lot of us
can't donate but what are the actual
risks of having sexually active gay men
donating blood
well HIV is no longer a death sentence
and heterosexual people are also at risk
of contracting the virus men who have
had sex with other men remain at the
highest risk of infection in 2016 40,000
people were diagnosed with HIV in the
u.s. of those gay and bisexual men
accounted for 67% but science has come a
long way since the ban was introduced
donated blood in the u.s. is not only
tested to see which patient can the
blood go to but also to look for
possible diseases or infections that
might be present in the blood so in
theory most donations from people who
are HIV positive will show up in the
results and therefore
we'll make it to a blood bank but the
concern lies in what they call a window
period the window period is a time
between when the virus is contracted and
when it's a tech table the risk here is
that someone could contract the virus
and donate blood before it shows in the
test the reality is that HIV screening
tools have a significantly improved
since 1983 now we have a shorter window
period and more sensitive tests after
the window period has passed using the
testing methods of 1987 tests after an
eight week window show a chance of
infection in one out of every 150 3123
units of blood with today's methods a
risk of infection is one in eight to
twelve million units of blood so what
does this matter well as it turns out we
need blood in 2018 the Red Cross sounded
the emergency alarm for blood shortage
and these shortages are coming
throughout the country this constant
blood shortages are cured partially
because only 38 percent of the u.s.
population is eligible to donate blood
and only about 10 percent donate blood
yearly according to the Red Cross a
person in the US as in need of blood
every two seconds and one pint of blood
could save up to three lives lives like
Nathan's in Arizona Nathan was born on
August 24 2014 a healthy baby boy
three and a half months Nathan started
to look as if he had jaundice his belly
was really extended and I started to
question his appearance and how he was
behaving I took him into his primary
care physician they drew some blood and
I received a phone call around 11
o'clock that night telling me that my
son's hemoglobin was a four and his
spleen was in his pelvic cavity and I
needed to take him to Phoenix Children's
Hospital right away and we spent the
next nine days in Phoenix Children's
Hospital within that nine days Nathan
received three blood transfusions back
to back Nathan was having weekly blood
transfusions and they slowly spread out
to about two weeks and then eventually
three weeks now Nathan just received his
61st blood transfusion and he can go
anywhere between three to four weeks
before having to receive another blood
transfusion there was a time that we
were asked to come back the next day
because they didn't have his type of
blood in the blood bank in worst case
situations like natural disasters things
like that like that is a really scary
feeling because without blood
transfusions my son will pass away and
at that time it doesn't matter who is
donating the blood it's the fact that
we're getting blood for my little boy
and people just like him
I sign a document stating that I
understand that he can contract HIV but
the benefit of my son receiving blood
completely outweighs that risk could
because without a blood transfusion
there is no other way for him to be
alive if he will die so yeah I'm gonna
take that risk
I'll take blood from anybody who's
willing to get it and that means more
than anything in the world to me the
life of my son truly is in other
people's hands and that is the worst
feeling in the world to feel as a parent
now while the u.s. recently lifted the
lifetime ban there are other countries
that have screening processes that might
allow us to donate more blood in Spain
and Italy for instance each donors
potential risk is approached
individually to determine high-risk
blood donors for example if a gay man is
in a long-term monogamous relationship
he could be considered low risk for HIV
and therefore is safer candidate on the
other hand a straight man may be
considered high-risk if he's recently
had unprotected sex with multiple
partners blanket assumptions based on
sexual orientation are avoided with this
individual approach and screenings
become based more on what is described
as risky sexual behavior and not
necessarily who you're attracted to or
who you have sex with
you